hey youtubers is charlie so the BBC just
released a brand new trailer for Doctor
Who series 8 and it was mostly to
announce the premiere date of august
twenty-third which was kind of when I
expected it to be even though it was a
really short clip we still got loads of
new information so this is going to be a
breakdown of all that hello to all the
new people if you're finding me for the
first time I'm doing Doctor Who videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything whenever episode one does
premiere I'm actually gonna do a special
giveaway it'll be just like my game of
thrones giveaway and the legend of korra
one that i'm doing right now so i'll be
sure to explain that whenever we get
closer so important stuff like I said
Doctor Who series 8 episode 1 will air
saturday august twenty-third on BBC one
and BBC america i don't know all the
channels that it airs on internationally
because it airs in many many countries
but it's basically going to be on the
same station at the same time on the
same day that it's always been it wasn't
super hard to guess that that was when
the premiere was going to be august
twenty-third it's just the first
Saturday after the last day of their
world tour if any of you guys actually
do end up going to those world tour
dates be sure to let us know in the
comments if it's coming to a city near
you you should really try and go because
it's gonna be a lot of fun the one
that's coming to America is in New York
City so I won't be able to see just
because I live in California but that's
okay so now let's break down that new
trailer I'm just going to be covering
things as they appear the first thing we
notice is the huge change to the stock
of the TARDIS console it's read a very
very ominous read the TARDIS interior
itself doesn't look too different which
is expected since they spent about 2
million dollars building Matt Smith a
new TARDIS in the 2012 christmas special
the snowmen I'd say the Companions like
Clara being able to travel in multiple
TARDISes is a really rare thing but
since the 2005 reboot it seems like most
of each doctor's final companion gets to
see that next TARDIS and the next Doctor
so if you are like a doctor's final
companion the chances that you'll get to
travel in a new TARDIS are pretty good
it's hard to argue if Capaldi's TARDIS
is going to be new because they're
really just changing the stock of the
console it's a big change but not super
huge until we get a better look at the
interior I'm just going to call it a
minor revision but not full on new I
predict that they're going to make some
minor changes to the interior skin but
the superstructure as well as the gal
frame symbols up at the top are going to
stay the same the explosions we've seen
before they're just a continuation of
the explosions that started whenever
Matt
regenerated into Capaldi episode 1 is
gonna pick up like right as the
Christmas specials ending like in that
moment where cars like oh my god who is
this new doctor it does kind of seem
like the TARDIS always crashes during a
regeneration whenever tenant regenerated
into matt smith he still knew how to fly
it but it was severely damaged which is
one of the reasons why he didn't come
back for Amelia pond at the right time I
do have another theory about the girl
who waited just because it seems like
the TARDIS has an awareness that's a
little bit sharper than the doctors I'm
guessing it actually took Matt Smith to
adult Amelia pond on purpose not because
it malfunctioned like we heard interests
saying the doctor's wife I may not take
you where you want to go but I always do
take you where you need to go I love how
that implied that the doctor has
absolutely no idea what he's doing and
he's just making things up as he goes
along but that might also be Steven
Moffat making fun of himself just a
little bit the voice-over Capaldi has as
its oom sin on his eyes a little
sinister Clara be my pal tell me am I
good man the delivery on that makes it
sound like he's asking as if he's not
sure he wants to be a good man there was
this April Fool's joke that the BBC was
doing where they basically put it out
that Capaldi was secretly the master in
disguise I don't know that the BBC was
behind it it might have been someone
else but that was absolutely ridiculous
just because we saw Matt Smith
regenerate into Capaldi Moffat did
reveal that Capaldi's doctor will be
much less accommodating Stern was the
word used specifically but I think it
just implies that he won't be as
inclined to help others as he was in the
past if that's the case obviously the
doctor has to keep helping people so the
responsibility of getting him to help
people will fall on Clara and the other
new companions that join up if you
haven't seen any of my other videos for
series 8 I actually explained who those
new companions are going to be it's
basically the Danny pink character and
his sister so somewhere after episode 4
there will be three companions
travelling in the TARDIS Clara's line in
the trailer even though it comes right
after the Capaldi voiceover isn't
answering him directly I don't think I
know who the doctor is anymore is from a
different scene that's probably taken
from that first episode which means she
might be talking to Madame vastra
because we've seen pictures of her on
set for that episode it stands to reason
that the doctors friends would be
confused by Capaldi's behavior post
regeneration especially if he doesn't
care about them the way he used to so
then there's this really interesting
zoom in on his eyeball which I think has
some hidden imagery we just see his iris
in his pupil but part of me wants to
think that the imagery is also supposed
to be a visual reference to either a
black hole or the time vortex that we
see in the opening credits or the
untempered schism which we haven't seen
since the end of time or even the eye of
Harmony there are a lot of eyeball
references in Doctor Who so it could be
a reference of things that they're going
to be bringing back in series eight or
maybe some things that we might see in
the future if not in series eight the
last thing that you may have missed
unless you watch the teaser a few times
was Capaldi's modified intro music it
plays like right at the end for just a
brief second Steven Moffat is updated
the opening credits a few times while
he's been showing her you know not huge
changes just really small subtle ones
remember whenever they broadcast the
50th anniversary they use the original
intro from that first broadcast it's
changed a lot since then but the same
basic tones are there that's really the
one big thing they haven't shown off yet
Capaldi's official opening credits scene
there have been a lot of fan versions
but I'm wondering if they're gonna show
it off a comic con next month or if
they're just gonna wait to that first
episode sometimes whenever they take
footage to comic-con it's really just a
highlight reel like they don't show like
a lot of brand new footage that you
don't already see like last year at
comic-con they basically showed what
ended up becoming the first teaser
trailer for the 50th anniversary so it's
not a huge deal if you're not in Hall H
whenever that's happening there's
nothing that they're going to show in
there that you won't also see at the end
of august so no worries but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
below what do you think that that red
TARDIS console means and do you think
there's any hidden imagery in Capaldi's
I whenever it seems in on that so
because I have a ton of other videos to
do this weekend there's a bunch of stuff
happening I'm not going to do a Q&A for
this so just write your comments on this
video and I'll try to answer as many as
possible saturday is basically going to
be my new Doctor Who day if it hasn't
been already here's what my bonus videos
are going to look like tilt episode 1
premieres it'll be one video every
Saturday not including comic-con weekend
there'll be some extra stuff then then
the week episode one airs I'm going to
do a saturday morning bonus video then
an episode review that night and then a
QA on Sundays you know one for each new
episode so that's like 36 plus Doctor
Who videos during the season and then
it'll go just back down to that one
video per week I will be doing some
extra stuff for the Christmas special
just like I did last year but I'm gonna
wait till we get a little bit closer to
talk about that just because it's so far
off so in the meantime be sure to
subscribe to get every
I'm so excited about series a it's going
to be a lot of fun if you're a big fan
of classic who you're really going to
like series eight right now click here
to get a breakdown of all the episodes
and click here to learn about my top 10
people that I'd like to see become
Doctor Who companions in the future
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives
you